it's very important I've seen this
elsewhere that you bring in things that
are new you discover new things that
change you in a way and that by you know
processing this new information
then you are
maintaining the the youth and the the
activity of your of your brain which is
very important uh of course other things
being active is very good for your brain
uh jogging is good for a brain so many
things are good for your brain but it I
don't know that we need to think of it
always in terms of doing it because it's
good for our brains if we are genuinely
curious then we derive tremendous
satisfaction from learning about other
places learning a travel is a form of
learning about other places uh learning
languages of course which is what I'm
doing now learning polish because I'm
going to Poland I mean I did have some
previous exposure to polish uh so it's
this curiosity rather than how many
years we've spent